MATT GAUNT: Another Android
Office Hours from the somewhat
snowy London.
My name is Matt Gaunt
I'm joined with--
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
MATT GAUNT: Yep.
And we're going to be discussing
all things Android.
Here's your disclaimer, we
don't talk about future
releases, or future
announcements, or anything
that we might be doing.
We are literally here to talk
about the APIs that we've got
and to try and help
you guys out.
CHRIS BANES: Sorry we're
a bit late today.
We ran into a couple of
technical difficulties.
MATT GAUNT: One after
the other.
CHRIS BANES: Yep.
MATT GAUNT: But we're here.
It's all good.
CHRIS BANES:We got
Rich cc Giuseppe
as well in the hangout.
Hey, [? Giuseppe, ?]
how are you doing?
GIUSEPPE: Thanks, good.
WIEBE ELSINGA:Hi guys.
MALE SPEAKER: I just joined in
case I could help with the
technical difficulties.
But I'm actually in Mountain
View at the moment.
So it's six o'clock
in the morning.
So I'm going to drop out and
leave these guys to it.
I was useless anyways.
I'll catch you guys later.
Cheers everyone.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Beware
of the jet lag.
CHRIS BANES: How's
things for you?
Wiebe?
WIEBE ELSINGA:Who me?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, Wiebe.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Great,
a little bit tired.
But it's the flu season so
everybody's a little bit sick.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, not good.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I just about
managed to stave away from
that from CES.
CHRIS BANES: Anything
interesting at
CES when you went?
MATT GAUNT: Yes, lots of new
Google TV devices were in
there, which I'm sure people
were keen to see.
CHRIS BANES: [LAUGHTER]
MATT GAUNT: We announced
partnerships with ASUS,
Netgear, TCO.
LG announced a new set of
TVs, as did Hisense.
So it was amazing.
No hand involved.
Hisense had massive billboards
and has snap films up
everywhere.
It's a really good event,
really, really
fun place to start.
Lots of Miracast devices
as well.
Start to lay out
the wood work.
CHRIS BANES: That's good.
Cool.
Any questions in the room?
GIUSEPPE: [SPEAKING
FOREIGN LANGUAGE.
CHRIS BANES: Say that
again, Giuseppe.
MATT GAUNT: Everyone's having
technical issues as well.
CHRIS BANES: Wiebe, I know you
have a question, because it
was in the moderator.
Do you want to ask it live?
WIEBE ELSINGA: Yeah.
Now what we see, we see
more televisions.
We see Android's
smart watches.
We see Google glasses.
So I was wondering if there's a
good technique to do pair to
pair with different devices.
CHRIS BANES: Wi-Fi direct is
the way we would prescribe
doing it from now on, really.
Network discovery, I
don't really know
what the acronym is.
MATT GAUNT: NDS, was it?
CHRIS BANES: NDS.
There is a big training sample
on developer.android.com which
is actually really good.
That's the way I'd point you to,
mainly because it's going
to be bundled through
Android from now on.
And you have quicker P2P
access [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the way [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: I think for me--
I don't think we've got to the
point where we've got a
unified API, one
size fits all.
I think, obviously, Google
TV we have any mode.
But that's very much the case if
you fling it off to the TV,
you can discover it.
But you can't then start
going backwards.
Then when you start talking
about smartwatches, obviously
all of them are using Bluetooth
as their way
communication that have Wi-Fi.
So I don't think there is just
a one solution fix all.
Obviously if there is a service
that you can use that
does all of this for you,
then look into it.
But obviously you'd start buying
into something that
they suddenly decide stop
supporting it, or they change
it, or suddenly there is a new
devices they don't want to
support, you are kind of
tied in to that point.
So I think NDS stuff
is probably quite
a safe way to go.
Just try and do whatever you
think is best and it fits in
right with your solution.
Just try to bear in mind, in the
future down the line, that
you may need to swap it out.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I will follow
the tutorial online, then.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah it's
a nice tutorial, nice
code and that stuff.
WIEBE ELSINGA:Cool, thank you.
MATT GAUNT: Cheers, Wiebe.
CHRIS BANES: Hey, it's looks
like we've got more guys.
We've got Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi, guys.
CHRIS BANES: Hey,
how do you do?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I'm fine.
I have a little question
if I can ask.
Or is there someone
else on the line?
CHRIS BANES:There is,
but go for it.
Ask the question.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
I'm trying to see--
to do some POC about
VideoView.
And what I was trying to do is
basically have a full screen
VideoView inside a view pager.
And on the video view I want to
show some custom buttons.
But every time I try to load the
video to the VideoView, I
get an error that the video
view cannot play the file,
even though when commenting all
the buttons or all of the
draw bars on top of
the video view,
the file plays correctly.
Any known issue about this,
or something like that?
MATT GAUNT: That's very weird.
You're definitely just using
a plain old video viewer.
You're not using the YouTube
player API are you?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, no, Video
View from the Android.
MATT GAUNT: That shouldn't
cause an issue.
CHRIS BANES: Have you tried with
the buttons, but not in a
view pager?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, also
the same results.
CHRIS BANES: It worked?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No,
it doesn't work.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Where is your
video source coming from?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: From
the SD card that I
have it on an SD card.
I also tried to do it
on raw data files.
WIEBE ELSINGA: And the
permissions is set correctly?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Sorry,
didn't hear you.
WIEBE ELSINGA: The permission
is set correctly?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yes,
yes of course.
I can--
if I just do a simple view
with VideoView on it, and
attach the media file, and
I just click on it.
And it plays correctly.
And the only problem is when I'm
starting to add the image
buttons, or any other text
views, or overlays on it
inside the relative layout, or
linear layout, whatever you
want, and the view doesn't
play the video.
CHRIS BANES: Video View is
basically a glorified
SurfaceView with lock integrated
media player from
[? chassis. ?]
And SurfaceView draws
differently to other views.
It sort of punches right
for the window.
So Android doesn't solve
optimization stuff to get it
to [INAUDIBLE].
And have a look at the
SurfaceView documentation,
because I remember there being
flag on there where you can
set a compatibility mode to make
it draw things on top.
But I can't remember off
the top of my head.
It's been a while since
I've used it.
But have a look at SurfaceView
and that class of
documentation, because
I'm pretty sure
there's a flag on there.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK I'll
try to see it.
And another question, I
didn't encounter it.
But we have a view pager with
a SurfaceView on it.
And basically when you do the
scrolling, scroll from side to
side, you see a black surface.
And the view doesn't render
from one view
page switch to another.
You know, like on the camera
when you switch from live
video to the gallery?
You see the gallery has
a black overlay?
CHRIS BANES: The reason for
that is because the way
SurfaceView works in that it
punches for all the windows.
So imagine your surface view is
right at the back of your
views, and it sort of
punches through.
So what your actually seeing it
the very back window, the
black, that's what
the black is.
And it's just because
the way it draws is
different to other views.
There's no real way around it,
unfortunately, other than not
using the SurfaceView.
Obviously don't use it if you
don't really have to.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I didn't
see it until now.
We tried to do something with
the camera preview, and just
do a view pager scrolling
left to right.
And we saw that basically
the view
doesn't completely render.
Because on the Galaxy Nexus with
the Jelly Bean, it works
flawlessly.
You don't see the
black rendering.
On different devices, like on
the Samsung S2 or S3, you see
the black window stays until
the full window has been
switched in.
CHRIS BANES: This is probably
fixed in Jelly Bean then.
But it's just the
way SurfaceView
works, from what I know.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
Thanks guys, I'll try.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Hi, can
I ask a question?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, go for it.
MALE SPEAKER 2: I have
two questions please.
The first one is how to change
the Stack Overflow icon
programmatically.
Like when switching when I have
action bar overflow, it
switches programmatically.
Any idea?
CHRIS BANES: You want
to switch the icon?
MALE SPEAKER 2: The
icon, yeah.
The scenario is that
I have several--
I have a split action bar, the
action bar, and then the
action mode as well, which is
the contextual action bar,
another term for it.
And I have two different
backgrounds for the action bar
and the split action bar.
They are both in contrast
to one another.
So the overflow looks hidden
on the dark if
it's light and light.
And it looks hidden
in vice versa.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
is to use the [INAUDIBLE]
and not use the [INAUDIBLE]
action bar.
Just use action [INAUDIBLE].
We access [INAUDIBLE]
there's no way.
If you get access to the source
from the drawables,
then you can change it.
MALE SPEAKER 2:OK.
Thank you.
And then my second question
is, I want to play--
Alexander, hi.
Can you please turn off
the microphone?
I think we have background
noises.
The microphone, not
the earphones.
CHRIS BANES: It's all right,
it'll be just me anyways.
Don't worry.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So my
second question is
regarding HLS mime type.
I understand that Android as
of 3.0 supports HLS plane.
And I have problems with it
before they got fixed.
But there isn't any HLS mime
type that triggers the
activity of the player.
I gave the wrong mime type to
play the HLS just for default
player activity to pop up.
But what's the mime type?
What's the formal mime type
that the default player
supports for HLS?
MATT GAUNT: I think HLS,
you want to package it
up as MP4, I think.
And there is something in that
file which will then--
where is that coming from?
MALE SPEAKER 2: So that's
what I did.
I ran--
I got the MP4 mime type.
And it runs, but there
may be players that
supports MP4 but not HLS.
So--
MATT GAUNT: Well, it will be the
Android page platform that
will be supporting HLS.
The way you want to do it, if
you wanted to ensure the
players that didn't support HLS
weren't getting played in
that way, using that file,
then you'd want to be
basically [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER 2: Sorry,
I didn't get it.
MATT GAUNT: You want to be using
the Android version code
if you only want it to
play the HLS stream
on Android and above.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So how do I
run only the activity of--
I need to run, specifically, the
built-in players activity.
Right?
I invoke intent to
run the activity.
I'm not using the player
as part of the app.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Yeah so all you want to do
invoke the activity.
You want to invoke the activity
depending on which
version of Android
you're running.
Is that right?
MALE SPEAKER 2: But--
MATT GAUNT: Or HLS?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah, but--
for example, a Samsung is
perhaps Samsung implement
their own activity, and
it's a different
package name or something.
MATT GAUNT: So what you want to
be doing is basically using
the action underscore
[INAUDIBLE]
intent, and run that way.
Here's an MP4 file
that [INAUDIBLE]
is capable of playing it, or
then be given the chance to
basically [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER 2: OK, so there
is a delay here, sorry.
I'm listening.
MATT GAUNT: The other thing I
was going to is, since all
versions of Android
[INAUDIBLE]
play your HLS stream correctly,
you basically just
want to make sure that you
launch that intent on those
versions of Android and above.
MALE SPEAKER 2: OK.
But the problem is that if I run
the intent with MP4 mime
type, what will happened is that
players that support MP4
will catch this.
But I saw some players that
support MP4, but do not
support HLS, which is
kind of a wrapper
around MP4, that's right.
But they still don't
support it.
MATT GAUNT: Could you post in
the chat which devices you're
referring to?
And maybe we can help
dig around.
MALE SPEAKER 2: It's more like
what players are supported.
Because if a user installs two
players that support MP4 but
from the Play store, they
install two players that
support MP4 but not HLS, they
won't play my video.
MATT GAUNT:I guess it depends,
because if they're using a
player which is implementing
their own media codex and
their own encoding/decoding, and
they're not be relying on
the Android systems.
At which point, I guess, a
difficult way would be trying
to get that across to a user.
I mean, the obvious choice is
to, since you know you're
going to be able to run it on
certain devices of Android,
run it in video viewer.
That way you kind of
get control of it.
There's media controllers you
don't have to do any controls
or handling password, rewinding,
et cetera.
So it should be relatively
trivial just to add in your
own video viewer, which
might be a good way
to get around this.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So how do I skip
around implementing all
of the controllers, the fast
forward, the seek to bar, and
stuff like that?
MATT GAUNT: When you create a
video viewer you can just also
set a media controller.
And then provided you set that
media controller, which,
again, is just a class that is
just handed to you, it'll just
[INAUDIBLE] the VideoView
for you.
MALE SPEAKER 2: OK.
So can we request to
add the HLS mime
type in future releases?
MATT GAUNT: That goes on to a
much larger issue of the way
HLS handles is itself.
So it's not necessarily
mime type.
I think that would be more to do
with a standard issue of an
Android just sitting there
saying here's a mime type, use
it for Android only.
I think it would need to be a
slightly bigger discussion.
I don't think that's something
we could necessarily do.
Because like I said, I think
it's one of those things that
Apple has obviously created
the standard--
made it so that MP4 is the
way of dealing with it.
That's kind of the standard.
Maybe it will change.
MALE SPEAKER 2: OK.
So it's kind of more of
just the activity
of the media player.
It's just the activity, the
intents that the activity of
the media player can handle?
That's it, right?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, exactly.
MALE SPEAKER 2: OK.
OK, Thanks.
CHRIS BANES: Anyone else
have a question?
MALE SPEAKER 3: Can
I ask a question?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, sure.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Thank you.
So I have an app that's
[INAUDIBLE]
that relies on [INAUDIBLE]
API.
And I choose a random song
selected by genre.
And then I play and the
user has to get us the
name and the artist.
But I provide the registration
for these to have the
rankings and so on.
But do I have to provide a
privacy policy inside the
output, or on the Google
Play store in
the appropriate section?
MATT GAUNT: So I think the
Play store changed its
regulations regarding the
privacy policies.
You have one now, or--
CHRIS BANES: You either have to
have one, or you explicitly
say you're not going
to provide one.
MATT GAUNT: OK.
My recommendation would be
definitely to have one on the
Play store.
And then if you've got a
convenient place where can
have in the app and it makes
sense for you to have it in
the app, in terms of you've got
a settings page, you can
just put it into there.
And you've got a nice easy way
of keeping the two in sync,
I'd go with that.
I don't see any reason if you've
already gone through
the time to prepare it, and
you've got a spot where it can
live in the app without being in
the way, then I'd say just
include it.
But I don't think
it's required.
MALE SPEAKER 3: OK but it's not
a legal problem if I don't
put it in there, put
it inside the app?
MATT GAUNT: It's not a legal
problem in terms of us.
It's more of a legal
problem, I guess,
between you and the user.
I can't really comment because
I don't know that much about
it, because I'm not in legal.
MALE SPEAKER 3: No, it is
because I don't know if I must
provide a privacy policy.
Because the user,
to me, is data.
So I must protect this data.
I have to say OK, this data
I've stored is protected.
You are right.
CHRIS BANES: I would always
bundle the privacy policy with
the app, just in case
your app isn't
distributed with Play store.
So if it goes into Amazon app
store or any other sort of
distribution channel, and they
don't allow you to show a
privacy policy, it's always
going to be with your app.
MALE SPEAKER 3: OK.
CHRIS BANES: So it's
a fail safe.
So I would always do it.
If you took the time to create
one, shoving it in your assets
folder and then create
a web view.
It's not much work.
MALE SPEAKER 3: OK, thank you.
MATT GAUNT: I guess it kind of
leads on to a slightly wider
picture of [INAUDIBLE].
Then if the user goes through
the time to actually hunt that
out, then it probably means
that they're slightly
concerned about your app.
And it's probably good way of
putting their mind at ease.
That's another way of looking
at it as well?
MALE SPEAKER 3: OK, thank you.
CHRIS BANES: So have
we got any more
questions in the moderator?
Go ahead, Giuseppe.
I knew you'd have one.
GIUSEPPE: All right.
I have a question about
the Google Drive SDK.
Is this the right place to
ask for this question?
CHRIS BANES: We can try and
answer, we don't know--
MATT GAUNT: It's one where you
need Rich and Nick here.
They can go around during
developer days on this.
But go for it.
GIUSEPPE: OK, that's good.
I'm trying to get the token
[INAUDIBLE] orientation using
the new Google Play services.
And I combined this with
the Google Drive SDK.
Sometimes the Google Drive SDK,
they turn to me, and now
object, no exception on the
upload of the file.
But this happened very,
very randomly.
So this is not a pack, but it
starts something concerning
the web server, or
I don't know, the
services from Driver.
Anyone got some experience
about that?
CHRIS BANES: I'd probably guess
that it's the connection
issue, maybe?
Maybe the connection dropped out
for a millisecond while it
was uploading.
And it doesn't do any retrying
so you might need to do--
implement that yourself.
GIUSEPPE: No, I don't know.
I already tried to clear the
cache and everything.
I also found on Stack Overflow
a question like this without
any answers.
If you want I can share
the questions.
Because I believe that
there is some
problem with the service.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, share the
question for the Stack
Overflow link.
And we'll try and to give it
to Rich and Nick, because
they've got far more experience
for the Drive SDK
than we have.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
I will find it right now and
I will put in the chat.
So you can go to another
question with someone else.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks, Giuseppe.
Are there any other questions
in the chat?
Oh, we're going to get
some moderator.
Let's get some moderator
questions on the go.
Right.
So here's a question from Jay
Dixon, who asked, as there's a
cache management in the Google
Play in that purchase sort of
flow in version for it, it's
asking how do you actually
clear the cache when you're
actually making changes to
prices, to items, to whatever
you need to, really?
Do you want to answer?
MATT GAUNT: No, you go for it.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
So from what I gather, when
you're making changes to your
in-app purchases, the Google
Play client will actually be
notified, and it all
invalidates cache.
And so I'm pretty sure you can
just assume that any call that
you make, the cache is valid.
I think that's a pretty
safe assumption.
MATT GAUNT: I guess the only
time you might see issues is
it does take a long while for
updates in the Play store when
it comes to billing
to actually go
through to the app.
So you might have to
wait a little while
for that to go through.
If you've got a more
solid example,
drop us another question.
But yeah, I think, like
you said, Google Play
will sort it out.
CHRIS BANES: Andrew Kelly has
asked, "can you please confirm
the current refund period on
the Google Play Store?
Is there any way
to [INAUDIBLE]
misses?"
MATT GAUNT: I'd like
answer to this.
No you can not do it.
And the main reason I kind of
like that is [INAUDIBLE]
if you're trying to find that
out, I question what you're
trying to do with it.
I like the idea.
Well, I don't like the idea.
I just can easily see how
people would take
advantage of that.
CHRIS BANES: It's ony
changed once.
So I can't gather it's not going
to change for a while,
if it does.
But we don't know.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: If the Google Play
team decides they want to
change it, then it is probably
due to customer.
They've obviously got a good
reason for doing it.
Obviously that's when
we'll make a public
statement, et cetera.
CHRIS BANES: But it's not
going to be a regular
occurrence.
It's not going to be something
that happens dynamically.
MATT GAUNT: I think that's
point where changing it
regularly will confuse
developers as well as
consumers, which we
don't want to do.
CHRIS BANES: We've got
more questions on
the monitor, actually.
"How difficult is it to enable
printing from within Android?
How different are the APIs, the
version two and version
four?" From Kevin.
MATT GAUNT: I have no
experience with the
Google Print API.
So I couldn't comment.
Have you played with It?
CHRIS BANES: I haven't
played with it.
MATT GAUNT: I don't know,
to be brutally honest.
That might be a question
to try again next week.
We can probably copy it over
from the moderator.
Perhaps Rich or Nick will
have a better idea.
If not, we'll go away and
look at it and come
back with an answer.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah all after
this, because these have come
in recently.
MATT GAUNT: I might have a
chance to look at them.
Have you got any
more questions?
So there's a question, "can
anyone tell me how to override
slash hide outgoing
calling screen in
Android?" Nejandra, I think.
I could have just destroyed
that name.
I'm sorry if I have.
So yeah, Chris is kinda pointing
out that it's the
action new outgoing calls
broadcast which you can
essentially register
to be overridden.
I also recommend looking
at Sipdroid.
It's an open source
voiceover IP app.
But generally, I'd say look at
the documentation, you'll get
a good idea of what's
going on.
And then if you look at any
examples, then Sipdroid is a
quite nice way of then going
and digging around.
CHRIS BANES: I'd worry
about what you're
trying to do with this.
If you're trying to implement
calling yourself, like if your
trying create [INAUDIBLE]
[? clones ?] or something, then
yes, a valide use case.
But if you're trying to sort
of hide someone's trying to
call their GSM, or whatever, I'd
worry about that, because
I'm not sure why you'd
need to do that.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I think
it's just a bit
of a niche use case.
I think the time I had to look
at it was a company that
wanted to tell whether you were
making an international
call or not.
I'd say be very careful.
Because like you say, you're
kind of just kind of
integrating really heavily
with the core purpose of
someone's phone.
CHRIS BANES: Especially as
people know what the layout
is, how to sort of turn the
speaker on and off, mute, all
that kind of stuff.
MATT GAUNT: I think it's the
prime candidate for just
giving a tutorial.
It's like what's going to happen
when they've installed
your app and enabled
certain things.
CHRIS BANES: I agree.
MATT GAUNT: So did you
want to look at some?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: If anyone has
questions live, feel
free to jump in.
CHRIS BANES: So Andrew Kelly,
another question from Andy.
"With the drawable note DPI
bucket, could you give an
explanation of why you would
want to use this?
And how would the image look on
an XHDPI device compared to
a MDPI device?
Why would I want this
to happen?"
MATT GAUNT: We just had a brief
discussion about this
before we came online.
Basically if you think of MDPI
or DPI, et cetera, as being a
bucket, it's a range of pixel
density displays.
And it kind of simplifies the
way the developers can think
about the UI in terms of just
roughly, if it's MDPI, then it
will use [INAUDIBLE].
That's what I have to worry
about, as apposed to each
individual one.
But it will still get some
level of scaling.
Now say you probably don't
have that much use case
wanting to use no DPI.
Chris gave the example of where
you wanted to handle the
scaling yourself,
which is valid.
I've used it in the past where
I've wanted to literally just
have a pixel perfect image for
one single device that was not
going to be distributed
anywhere.
I'd argue if you were using it,
then you're probably using
in such a niche use case that
you're completely aware of
what the limitations
are going to be.
But yeah, generally I'd
say most people
wouldn't need to do this.
Only if you need to get it out
unscaled or untouched, pixel
for pixel, exactly the same.
I had a long answer
to that one.
CHRIS BANES: Primary example
of when to use it is in
documentation for widget
previews, as in version 3
onwards, you've gotten
at sort of the end.
Widgets and ListView,
GridView, all
that kind of stuff.
And the documentation says to
put your widget preview in the
DPI, just because the launcher
does all the scaling for you.
As an example, it's just getting
rid of user if you
want to scan yourself.
Peter Brookes has asked, "are
there any suggestions for
respondents of apps affecting
your app, but not free, not
audio channels, given the
[INAUDIBLE]?" Not really.
There's no way you can really
control audio manager, how
that sort of just distributes
channels.
So there is no way, really.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I think
generally it's the case of
kind of the honor system.
If you're playing around with
that kind of stuff, I know
when you're told to kind of
show yourself how do it.
I can't think of any situation
how you could overcome that,
beyond informing the user about
what's going on and
telling them we're trying to do
this but we can't, because
of other applications.
Perhaps consider closing them.
CHRIS BANES: It would be
interesting what scenarios
you've got for this,
or why apps are
using so many channels.
It's got to be interesting how
they're trying to use so many
channels to sort of use
up your allowance.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: So if you can give
that in there, put that
in the response.
MATT GAUNT: "I'm having a
persistent but sporadic
problem with my web view.
It's consistent across
different handsets.
And I have no clue on what to
do." Stack Overflow, from
Minnie Bell.
I like that name.
So on 4.0.1, the web view
shows a blank page,
apparently.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
MATT GAUNT: So it looks like
they're just trying to display
some data just as a string,
uploading from a web service,
and doing a sort of encoding.
Can't say I can give you
an answer to that one.
CHRIS BANES: We'll do
that one offline, so
there's not one candidate.
MATT GAUNT: So it does
anyone else have any
questions in the hang out?
Come on, someone
must have one.
Oh, yeah, we haven't
looked at Hangout.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, we haven't
looked at Google+.
WIEBE ELSINGA: There's not much
questions, either, there.
CHRIS BANES: No.
So we're not very
popular today.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Back to
my question about
the VideoView again?
CHRIS BANES: What's
that Yossi?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Can
you hear me now?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I
can hear you now.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK, sorry.
About the VideoView again.
Basically what I did again, and
I just stripped all of the
image buttons and the drawables
and stuff from the
video view.
And put it on the view pager
and it's working.
On the view pager.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Sorry?
CHRIS BANES: No buttons
and it's working?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, no buttons
and it's working.
It's loading the video.
I can click on it and play,
click again, and it pauses and
resumes, and so on.
Any suggestions where to dig
up, or to see why when I'm
adding an image overlay
or something on top
of the video is--
CHRIS BANES: There's
a flag on surface
view from what I remember.
I'll have a quick dig now,
see if I can find it.
MATT GAUNT: I've seen people
overlay their own buttons on
video viewer.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I just posted
on the chat a simple app I
just stumbled upon.
It's called Video
Super Pop-up, or
something like that.
I'm not sure.
And basically what it does, it
has some nice neat UI packing
to enable a pop-up of all the
video you will be playing,
basically as a drag window.
All over your home screen is a
widget resize-able, and inside
the other applications.
And basically you have a window
with the video playing.
And you can interact with the
entire screen with different
activities.
I think it's using something
that it shouldn't
use, but I'm not sure.
MATT GAUNT: I've seen examples
of it done a
very simplistic apps.
I think my biggest concern is
the fact that because it's in
a view pager as well, whether
we're getting to a point where
something's just not
quite sitting.
CHRIS BANES: Yossi, did you say
it's not working out of a
view pager?
So if you don't use a view
pager, it doesn't work either?
MATT GAUNT: You've got
the same problem.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No,
I can't play video file.
Basically when I have the
VideoView inside of view
pager, it works.
Outside of view pager,
it works.
If I add buttons on top of
it, it doesn't work.
CHRIS BANES: Did you say it's
not happening across--
is it happening across all
versions of Android?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No.
I'm just testing on my Nexus
7 on my Galaxy Nexus.
I didn't test on the Android
2.3 or Gingerbread.
CHRIS BANES: There is a method
on surface view called "set Z
order on top," which will make
your SurfaceView try and draw
like a normal view.
So if you can try and get access
to the SurfaceView from
VideoView and then call that
method, set it to true, it
might work.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Peter Brookes
posted on the chat, "we
overlay buttons on video a lot
on our app." Which app?
ME code sample.
SurfaceView sets the
order on top--
oh, it's a game, "Broken Sword."
"Set the order on
top."
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, can't
remember if you can get the
SurfaceView from VideoView.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, I think I
need to override VideoView, Or
extend VideoView, and then
try to get some.
CHRIS BANES: Extend
SurfaceView.
So yeah, you can just
call "set Z order
on top" on the VideoView.
It should work.
But it will call, I don't
know if it will work.
[LAUGHTER]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically it
says the order is just to
change the stacking of the
elements on the layers.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
I can't remember the exact
way SurfaceView works.
But without it, It sort of
punches view from the back in
view window.
Whereas if you call true on "set
Z order on top," it does
some special stuff where it
kind of proxies the view.
So it looks like it's
a normal view.
I cant remember the
exact details.
I've done this kind of thing
before, and doing that worked.
But I don't know about
your scenario.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
CHRIS BANES: It would be quite
interesting if you can load up
a small sample that is doing
exactly the same thing.
It would be interesting
to see.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
I'll try to dig out only the
specific sample for the view
pager and stuff.
CHRIS BANES: That
would be good.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: And maybe do
some GitHub or something.
I'm not sure it will work
because basically I've tried
to do it in the last couple of
hours, and that's the first
time I saw something
like that.
I did video views before and
never had the problem of doing
an image overlay on top of it.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
Yeah, I can't say I'm
familiar with it.
MATT GAUNT: We've been joined
by someone else.
CHRIS BANES: That's, I
think, from earlier.
Any other questions?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Maybe Peter.
CHRIS BANES: We answered
one of Peter's.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, we answered
one of P. Brooke's.
If not--
CHRIS BANES: Do we have
any on Google+?
That one there.
MATT GAUNT: Google+ was empty.
I think we've gone through.
MALE SPEAKER 2: I'd like to
ask another question.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah go for it.
MALE SPEAKER 2: If
there's time.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So how do I know
if an action is found on
the split action bar instead
of the original action bar?
CHRIS BANES: You don't.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 2: With action
bar [INAUDIBLE]
perhaps?
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
I'm sure you could somehow.
It's supposed to be transparent,
so you're not
supposed to know.
You're supposed to set up the
app and then the split action
bar will show on certain
devices, mainly phones or
small devices.
MALE SPEAKER 2: What if I use
different backgrounds for one
light and the other one dark?
CHRIS BANES: So what was that?
You can use a light background
on the split?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah, and dark
background on the original.
And then I need to switch icons
to show the contrast.
CHRIS BANES: Oh, I
understand now.
Don't think any of
the others do.
MATT GAUNT: I think you
just want to give
them different IDs.
MALE SPEAKER 2: I don't think
I control the IDs.
I don't know what the IDs are.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
I don't think there's any
way you can do it.
There's no way of finding
out [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER 2: I didn't
hear that while I
tried to record it.
Thank you.
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
MATT GAUNT: Cool, well
I guess we don't
have any other questions.
CHRIS BANES: Looks
like we don't.
MATT GAUNT: Anyone else?
Last chance.
Going once--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Going twice,
sold to the guy
in the yellow shirt.
CHRIS BANES: OK, guys.
MATT GAUNT: Thank
you very much.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Thanks, guys.
Thanks.
CHRIS BANES: Call next week.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Bye.
Cheers, guys.